kessé rouverte hier d'une tristesse
c'est pas ton habitude qu'est ce qui
t'arrive tu savais que ce qui m'arrive
si tu savais que ce qui m'arrive
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu as perdu ton
travail
nok et perdu la vue même pas trouvé
d'abord je cherche même pas alors on
sais pas je ne veux pas chercher je vois
alors qu'est ce que tu as si tu savais
qu est ce qui m'arrive mexique
si tu me dis pas ce qui est arrivé ne
saurai jamais je crois que ma femme ne
me trompe
tu crois ou ai-je en est sûr je crois
que j'en suis sûr et y en a la preuve et
ouais elle a avoué a voulu y aller tu
crois toi tout ce que les femmes disent
je ne crois pas quand elle tue motif le
prix d'une robe ou d'un manteau ou d'un
bracelet ça je le crois pas mais quand
on dit ça je les crois c'est officiel
puccini alors là j'ai un très bon
conseil à te donner l'asile où on ne
parle à personne à personne
je m'entends à personne j'en appellerai
personnes au moins non je les ai juste
dit hazard fada afana malheureux bafana
le cela qu'il fallait pas parler un vrai
transistors son rival annoncés ouais
j'ai beaucoup d' influence sur lui je
venais le voir je vais lui dire de se
terrer tout s'arrangera mais ces deux
selon moi ouais enfin jeudi à kuito
aussi calmé tiendrait qu'à la marque 3 à
8 e store haut-parleurs qui marche 24
heures sur 24 mais tu annoncèrent tout
plats russes pas possible ça tu l'as dit
à george bush est aussi moi je les dis
tu vas dire prospère le cafetier ouais
je les dis alors tu l'as dit aussi à 100
vers le cordonnier est là il était fermé